no vôlei a minha sobrinha oliveira temos
agora viemos aqui apresentar o projeto
raio é com muito gosto que estamos aqui
deste lado este ano apresentar esse
projeto no ano passado estávamos a falar
com todos vós por isso não deixe de
acreditar e eles gostaram do projeto a
apresentação do projeto eu gostava de
pedir uma coisa será que toda a gente
aqui nesta sala 1950 um objeto está no
nosso cotidiano
então eu queria ter toda a gente que
pegasse uma folha que tem na capa e na
caneta e que pudesse fazer os gols e
disso eu guardasse para si
enquanto isso é que nós shows é nós
somos dois estudantes de 22 anos é somos
diferentes mas acabamos por nos conhecer
quando quando eu endereçamos não se
acertou e design produto
acabamos a licenciatura em 2013 e nesse
mesmo ano que nós temos no mestrado em
design integrado é que isso vá o projeto
o projeto raio
o projeto raio integra 19 alunos num
projecto de seis meses e com o intuito
de fazer uma bicicleta é bicicleta
deveria corresponder a três requisitos
deveria ter uma barreira ter três rodas
e também seria elétrica por além disso
todas as duas disciplinas estavam
ligadas à cadeia do projeto formato na
área
este projeto ainda mais forte no início
nós já temos uma parceria que era uma
empresa que brothers e também já
tenhamos um um padrinho que o ciclista
rui sousa não esquecendo a mãe que
deveríamos legará a as raízes da região
associando é a parte produtiva do minho
e também a sua cultura
e agora será que toda a gente a 1950
será que se eu fosse você e toda a gente
estaria certamente correta e completa
poderia andar
será que parece algo como isto
pois é muito bem estão uma experiência
eu criava mesmo específica criada com
funciona não é que a mostra que fala vai
usando conhecimentos ou seja r 50 e um
objeto tão do nosso cotidiano que o
nosso próprio cérebro o nosso próprio
cérebro enganados da forma como ela
funciona ou seja preferem ocultar
informações e criar um conhecimento em
nós mesmos do que nós a conhecemos do
que propriamente nós conhecemos mesmo e
isso acontece também com coisas no nosso
dia a dia como face por toda a gente
deve ter face paulo deve ter usado na
faixa de praia nesta semana e foi
perguntar a alguém como é que funciona
eu acho que muita gente vai saber por
que o funcionamento certo aqui
e foi por isso que nós fizemos isto
devemos aos 50 categorias porque é muito
mais fácil para nós ter grupo pequeno de
pessoas que percebem muito sobre parte
diversas bicicletas do grupo geral que
tem conhecimento médio daquilo que é a
bicicleta e livre existem categorias
mirim nos acessórios na direção no
quadro na propulsão humana e na
propulsão elétrica
após esta esta divisão ea divisão de
grupos é possível começar a nossa
primeira fase e começamos a primeira
fase que passa do de investigação de
todas aquelas partes em que não tenham
sido impedidos e da comissão deve
começar a produzir dos objetos ou seja
começar a desenhar e então na primeira
fase nós temos a fase de investigação
esta fase é nesta fase nós deveríamos
tentar perceber se coletas é que já
existem a forma de funcionamento 19 50 e
também todas as componentes que estão
ligadas à vela
desta forma
desta forma a todos os alunos tinham uma
tarefa que deveriam entregar na aula
seguinte de forma a fazer esboços e
esses votos eram eram iniciados todas as
aulas com intuitos no fim do dessa dessa
primeira fase temos várias opções e
então começa uma fase muito importante
após esta fase de pesquisa
começamos a receber objetos dos nossos
parceiros como por exemplo os limpa
fazer o estudo de medidas para ver
aquilo que podemos criar começamos a
passar tudo que eu tinha
ligado à promoção três dias conversar
com uma quarentena as partes estão a
desenhar se uma criança no design estava
conhecendo as formas e começamos a fazer
o levantamento de outras peças para
criar a possibilidade de produzir outros
materiais
então nesta nesta parte que temos um
workshop com um professor de zootecnia
no castelo o pessoal luís mota que teve
como tema de tese a um tema das
bicicletas e vai neste momento como era
uma fase inicial do projeto ainda vai
nos mostrar seus conhecimentos sobre o
sobre o tema
começamos então a receber mais materiais
foi temos aqui nesta fase entre o dono
de um quadro como foi decidido manter o
aluno do curso que prometeu perceber os
ângulos da bicicleta nos permitiu
perceber as medidas econômicas nos
prometeu começar a fazer um estudo das
medidas com as rodas para fora
mas a parte da montagem mas não não
esquecemos de tudo a parte da
investigação
e é na parte da investigação que está a
distância são a soja não tenham estado
cerca de um mês a trabalhar cada grupo
numa componentes era necessária uma nova
visão sobre os componentes todas então
todos os grupos foram trocados da mito
ou seja é um absurdo do quadro começaram
a trabalhar na direcção pessoa tira da
direção começaram a trabalhar nos açores
e assim sucessivamente
o que forneceu uma nova visão sobre tudo
isso nessa fase também começamos a fazer
encomendas de peças que eram necessárias
como funciona a mente que nós nós
poderíamos produzir o exame também é ter
uma certa noção do kalisa são ed espaço
carioca parte certas certos componentes
como por exemplo as baterias de um motor
e também começamos a fazer estudos com
pessoas que já não tenha sido fornecidas
como por exemplo os dois quadros
temos então agora que o estudo das
formas começamos então como um quadro
novo não tinha sido possível a montar as
peças que até então já tínhamos coletado
temos por exemplo as coroas temos as
pontas da franquia temos um problema que
já tenham sido materiais e temos um
estudo flynn
e aqui entra a parte dos nossos
acho que foi um dos parceiros
majoritários que é o terra sai com sua
esposa
temos aqui também estamos todos os dias
agronômicas com tudo aquilo que já tinha
adquirido até o momento
criamos uma espécie de modelo não
estando em uma bicicleta onde podíamos
testar as peças que já tínhamos de estar
as medidas que estamos a estudar e
perceber até que ponto é que a postura
de absoluta 50 seria correto seria
incorreta
também em paralelo e não mandasse plenas
que o que faz para o mestrado e
continuamos a fazer testes de forças ou
seja o professor manoel ribeiro que se
encontra foi conosco habitual notórios
da escola e começamos a fazer os testes
de força da inflação está a extração e
corrupção nas mangueiras para perceber a
possibilidade de criar outro tipo de
peças que até então não tinha sido
criadas em madeira é naquele tempo
materiais
a história faz a terceira fase é a
última equipe nós vamos concluir a
discussão do do protótipo é e nós
começamos a primeira fase com 11 com a
união de todas as maquetes até ea tela
produzidas para ver sam células se
encaixavam mãe
temos aqui novamente os juros de forma a
que já estamos numa fase mais avançada
já começamos a reunir os materiais como
por exemplo a importância da corticeira
amorim e os usuários da rodovia e
podemos começar a perceber as formas e
realizar projetos aqui jazz cuja já
começamos a pôr as mãos nas obras as
obras iam trabalhar com materiais
temos aqui também como por exemplo o kit
brasileiro que não pode ser produzido em
portugal porque o preço unitário fica
muito caro produzir um clique aqui ou
seja tivemos que mandar vir de fora e
temos as peças foram desenhadas por nós
em manaus produzir fora e novamente o
motor que tenha sido que já tinha
chegado a altura em termos de produção
de parceiros dos irmãos jacob viana do
castelo e aguardar as elétricas que uma
empresa espanhola depois de já termos
estas estas peças
é hora de começar a produzir tudo que
era necessário
começamos pelo quadro como devem saber o
quadro é uma
bastante importante no funcionamento da
uma bicicleta porque porque para além de
ser a peça que vai unir todas a todos os
restantes componentes também é uma peça
que que existe sobre ela uma força
enorme
por isso quando é encontramos a forma a
forma exata que que responder se esse
convite foi a foi a altura de começarmos
a fazer um levantamento da de medidas e
de seguida passamos para por uma versão
3d é uma versão 3d permitiu-nos usar a
utilizar cursos da escola como por
exemplo a ciência é o anjo foi produzido
o quadro mas nós não tenhamos todas as
todos o as possibilidades de produzir na
escola
desta forma juntou-se a nós uma uma
sessão que appcdm onde eu for possível
ou nos permitiram fazer a algumas
algumas funções que não conseguiríamos
fazer na escola foi condenado
anteriormente como está isso que
produzimos numa outra aula que foi
possível perceber que era possível a
produção de duas peças que até então não
era nós mais normais produzir nesse tipo
de materiais como por exemplo a eta o
guiador e guarda - foram todos
produzidos por um processo de laminação
sendo que o goleador foi produzido no
modo curva e foram produzidos com todos
com madeiras duras sendo estas mognos
cupira faia e pina foram depois tratadas
no nosso parceiro inicial que seria os
brothers que estão neste momento a
tentar se iniciar neste mercado
da mesma forma fluente
era uma coisa que inicialmente para nós
não iria ser produzido neste tipo de
materiais mas quando começámos a receber
materiais e perceber as suas
propriedades de cada tipo de material
que estamos a perceber que seria
possível a criação nos clean em cortiça
que era uma coisa que nunca tenha sido
feita quando tentam mostrar as formas
que vimos anos e fizemos maquetagem
fizemos as primeiras experiências com
colas o primeiro funcionamento da escola
como a cortiça e produzimos então os
portuguesa e depois destas peças
produzidas conseguimos fazer a primeira
maquete funcional é neste dia que nós
conseguimos fazer o primeiro manter
funcionando e conseguimos perceber que
funcionava
foi um grande passo e planos é com esta
primeira máquina e funcional que nós nos
dirigimos a onde nosso concelho de
esposende para colocar peças que seriam
necessários indicados por aí fora e
seria muito mais fácil fazer no local do
que fazer o nosso nossas relações
é também aqui que nós percebemos quando
temos um novo projeto pronto e começamos
a olhar e ao sair do papel e queremos
que tem problemas e que nós começamos a
resolver esses problemas mas que são
jovens com sucesso e ainda fortalece o
processo
quando nós percebemos que tudo estava a
funcionar mãe
tivemos que passar à fase seguinte às
11h por todas as peças como últimas
fizemos o último quadro quadro do
protótipo final fizemos exatamente da
mesma forma kaká maquete funcional ou
seja pela parte da população e de
seguida pela parte da da ciência
a única diferença aqui é que ama da ilha
já era adequada às forças que iriam ser
exercidas e também já o acabamento para
além do quadro depois do quadro foi de
anos de observar fazer outras peças como
por exemplo as pessoas em cortiça é
surgiram com o patrocínio da corticeira
amorim e estes que acabaram por servir
para proteger o qual é
todas as peças que estavam dentro do
quadro e também a forçar o mesmo na
parte das horas acrescentar mas também
uma mala constituída por duas peças que
foi produzida por um artesão local onde
o clima é um caso também vai buscar a
tradição das raízes culturais ea mala
tem duas funções é mais pequena que
trabalha com uma mala de ferramentas
e tenha maior que trabalha com uma
pochete como viveu a primeira chegou a
andar com algum tipo de mercadoria e
guardar um quando campo se cuida é o
sexto sexta surgiu com a inspiração de
do xixi normais de fruta e porque quando
nós andamos de bicicleta ainsi va temos
um local para pôr colocar as coisas
então juntamente com com a empresa
dadá ppm e com o artesão de ponte de
lima que trabalhou com conseguimos fazer
o sexto
e como vimos anteriormente também foi
possível utilizar outros recursos
presentes na escola e foi como é como
três brinca que nós pagamos e produzimos
os apoios do guarda lamas e as peças que
cobrem as portas para dar um aspecto
mais mas profissional um aspecto melhor
mais técnico à bicicleta e aqui nessa
montagem final quando todas as peças é
que foi uma fase bastante 3 porque foi a
parte em que nós tínhamos que perceber
que tudo dava certo e foi o dia em que
nós conseguimos perceber isso e assim na
chave com lula e agora vincula e toda a
gente agora porque o da última vaga
inglesa e o veículo vai do do canal
online micro bicicleta ou seja era uma
forma de aliar a vez da bicicleta que
era mas ainda há um estilo mais urbano e
mais mais 40 como aquilo que os dias 2 e
agora nesta partida temos que agradecer
a todos os nossos parceiros e como vimos
no início como estamos com bastante
premissas e acabamos com um um conjunto
enorme de pessoas que nos apoiaram e com
uma bicicleta pronta funcional um
protótipo excelente profissional e que o
senhor me dado muito
passamos para a quarta fase a quarta
fase não estava explícita na nas fases
de avaliação mas depois de bicicleta
concluída porque tivemos quer uma fase
importante essa fase foi a fase de
divulgação da comunicação e da interação
das pessoas é que passamos a apartir das
sessões fotográficas e da imprensa
envolver conosco e aqui começam as
apresentações da imprensa temos como por
exemplo o jornal lá pega o terra na
faixa que fez uma publicação por causa
do dossiê importância da corticeira
amorim
temos publicações no público tem
explicações do observador
inicialmente começamos com complicações
nos jornais da região já na região
domingo cumpre-se a guarda do imã já tem
por exemplo uma entrevista para a tv e e
tenha largado as drogas os sensores anos
e é aqui que nós ficamos bastante
orgulhosos porque é donos não se
conhecem mas é uma uma vista então viana
conceituada na área da arquitetura e do
design e há cerca de um mês por não se
espante conseguimos foi publicada uma
notícia sobre o raio e ainda mais
orgulhosos ficamos quando nesta semana a
dom bush em ser o caio entre os dez
melhores bicicletas e aqui temos com as
pessoas porque não chove pois de
bicicleta concluída conseguimos perceber
o que significou para as pessoas é
interação que elas tiveram e até mesmo
nós conseguimos perceber que havia
pessoas que não não sabiam andar de
bicicleta e nesta conseguem é pessoas
com com problemas motores que nesta
bicicleta consegue
começamos a perceber o impacto que estas
bicicletas teve na vida das pessoas e
por isso é que nós achamos que mais do
que uma bicicleta nós conseguimos criar
as emoções e aqui está nossa escolha
ninguém tá feito
adriano